[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 29 janvier 2020
nouvelle édition de votre journal
quotidien d'information locale sur tv
60,18 voici les principaux titres qui
seront à développer le 24 février 2019
une conduite d'hydrocarbures avait cédé
à cause de la corrosion entraînant la
fuite de 900 mètres cubes de pétrole
dans deux champs situés à eau tout y est
voici sans avoir onze mois plus tard le
groupe total nous a donné accès au site
pour faire le point sur la dépollution
en cours c'est une figure de jouy en
josas jammes blum femme de léon blum
décédé en 1982 est à l'honneur de ce
long métrage
je ne rêve que de vous une séance vient
de se tenir en présence des comédiens et
d'historiens dans la maison occupée par
le couple à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale et puis en politique la
campagne des municipales se poursuit
pour les yvelines elle est à suivre sur
notre antenne interview ce soir de
lionel lindemann élu d'opposition à
magny les hameaux qui se présente face
au maire sortant
[Musique]
onze mois après la rupture d'un pacte
l'inao tout y est la fuite de 900 mille
litres de pétrole dans un champ nous
nous sommes donc rendus sur le chantier
de total les travaux de dépollution se
poursuivre pour réparer l'infrastructure
et permettre la réutilisation et des
champs agricoles en ci alors pardon que
sept associations environnementales ont
déposé une nouvelle plainte en se
constituant partie civile le reportage
de nicolas landry depuis le mois de mars
2019 le morceau du pipeline
d'ile-de-france à l'origine de la fuite
d'hydrocarbures a été remplacé 60 autres
défauts identifiés par un robot racleurs
ont aussi été corrigés avant une remise
en fonctionnement cet été le pas et
fonctionne à une pression opératoire
inférieure à celle qu'on avait avant la
fuite par arrêté préfectoral
vous voyez un espèce de tapis c'est un
géotextile de protection qui
qui sert à faire la jonction là la
différence physique entre les terres et
la partie technique du pai aps
au total cinquante mille mètres cubes de
terres polluées ont été retirés une
nouvelle phase vient de débuter sur le
chantier l'apport de nouvelles terres
sur les zones touchées par la fuite
nous sommes donc en train de rapporter
de la terre minérale autour du
'pipeline' pour le protéger et dans une
deuxième phase on en rapportera de la
terre minérales et de la terre végétale
pour permettre aux agriculteurs de
reprendre leurs pratiques culturales
classique on creuse plus ou moins
profondément en fonction de la qualité
des sols que l'on prélève et que l'on
fait analyser dans des laboratoires pour
savoir si on a des hydrocarbures ou plus
d'hydrocarbures des contrôles de
pollution sont encore effectuées
notamment à travers ses puits jaune pour
contrôler les nappes phréatiques pour ce
bois touchés par le déversement
d'hydrocarbures le nettoyage a été
effectué il ne sera pas abattu
notre analyse a montré qu'on pouvait
laisser des arbres en l'espèce recouvrir
d'humus le sol du petit bois et laissé
des traces d'hydrocarbures qui restait
être
des intérêts en fait par la nature elle
même et ainsi laisser les arbres
centenaires
le protocole de total a été envoyée à la
préfecture il doit recevoir la
validation de l'état la fin du chantier
prévue pour octobre 2020 dans
l'actualité également le préfet des
yvelines qui met fin de manière
anticipée aux carences concernant six
communes des arrêtés pris en 2017 pour
ne pas avoir respecté les 25 % de
logements sociaux mais depuis le pecq
joueurs qu'on chartrain chambourcy les
clayes-sous-bois que vous voyez ici
montesson et saint rémy les chevreuse
ont engagé des efforts jugés
satisfaisants elle récupère donc leur
droit de préemption leurs autorisations
d'urbanisme sur leur territoire mais les
pénalités financières restent exigible
pour celles qui n'ont pas atteint encore
le seuil légal minimum tout autre sujet
à présent la sixième édition du salon
bien-être c'est à voisins le bretonneux
organisé par l'association voisins
adultes relais le week-end dernier il a
permis aux participants de se détendre à
travers la technique la mieux adaptée à
chacun un sujet préparé par jade sixième
édition du salon du bien-être à voisins
le bretonneux dimanche 26 janvier
à cette occasion les visiteurs ont pu
rencontrer des professionnels implantés
sur une dizaine de stands
chaque année
il ya des intervenants nouveau et on
essaye justement de ne pas faire deux
années de suite avec les mêmes activités
le bien-être c'est être à l écoute de
soi à l'écouté des autres pour que
justement ce tout soit harmonieux cette
édition mettait à l'honneur la
découverte de nouvelles pratiques de
relaxation réflexologie plantaire ou
bien encore le yoga par le rire
nouveauté un stand était consacrée à la
compréhension des bébés ainsi qu'à
l'accompagnement des parents
j'accompagne les mamans ou les couples
avant pendant et après la naissance de
leur bébé touche vraiment le bien-être
parce que ça va être le bien-être de la
maman et du conte et du bébé parce que
je vais les accompagner vraiment de
manière émotionnelle et pas que médical
ya plein de petites choses qui sont un
peu comme un mezze finalement dans ce
salon on va puiser un petit peu dans des
choses
qu'on ne connaissait pas peut-être se
joindre à de nouveaux ateliers et puis
de faire de nouvelles découvertes pour
le bien-être se recentrer sur soi et se
détendre à chacun sa formule qui marche
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir à ce
6e salon une nouvelle édition aura lieu
l'année prochaine
ce week-end ce sera la troisième édition
de sport féminin toujours une opération
lancée par le ministère des sports en
partenariat avec le csa différentes
actions sont portés développement des
pratiques afin de corriger les
inégalités d'accès ou encore la lutte
contre les discriminations et les
violences faites aux femmes dans le
champ du sport et au vélodrome nationale
à montigny le bretonneux des animations
ont lieu le samedi dès 14h opération
100% filles vous en avez vu le logo il
ya quelques instants en 2019 la
fédération française de cyclisme n'a
recensé que 12000 54 licenciés féminine
soit seulement 10% de ses effectifs
nous parlons loisirs avec tom gauclin
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
marketing communication de vertical art
verticale art c'est une success story
qui social ouvert à travers la france
jusqu'à la réunion bientôt une ouvert de
nouvelles ouvertures de prévu on peut y
pratiquer l'escaladé mais pas seulement
on peut aussi s'installer au restaurant
au bar participer à des compétitions des
soirées dj aussi la salle de 50 ans
c'est la première qui était ouverte
exactement fin 2003 six ans plus tard
quel bilan vous faites comme je l'aï dit
c'est une success story donc on est très
fiers c'est là la première salle le coup
là en organise ce week-end une
compétition le samedi où on attend entre
200 et 300 compétiteurs
le matin les enfants l'après-midi le
haut niveau avec une finale très relevée
on va revenir sur cette compétition mais
déjà cette salle et une rénovation aussi
à l'année dernière ça vous a permis
d'accueillir un nouveau public et ce
sont d un public plus large peut être
aussi qui vient vous voir
tout à fait maintenant on peut
accueillir les enfants de moins de 4 ans
jusqu'aux jusqu'aux plus vieux de plus
de 70 ans avec des cours pour tout le
monde
un restaurant mise à jour une nouvelle
carte et un nouveau public
on envoie quelques 6 quelques images
mais comment ça fonctionne c'est
modulable ces parcours vous les adaptez
aussi il y en a plusieurs qui sont
proposés en fonction des âges parce
qu'entre 50 et 70 ans et puis les
professionnels aussi les plus aguerris
ce n'est pas la même chose tout à fait
on a huit niveaux de difficulté
les plus jeunes donc les moins de 4 ans
on a le niveau qu'on appelle le petit
dur on a 150 problèmes à résoudre dans
toute la structure qui sont renouvelés
du coup tous les mois et les projets en
cours de développement sur cette salle
sur cette salle non en france bien
entendu on a ouvert dernièrement à deux
pas du moulin rouge
on va ouvrir dans le xiiie
arrondissement de paris on va ouvrir
aussi à toulon grenoble marseille
donc voilà on est comme des succès
qu'est ce succès aussi rapide finalement
vous aviez prévu qu'il y aurait un
engouement aussi fort autour de l'
escalade l'intérieur intervient personne
ne pouvait le prédire
après nous on a été novateur sur notre
positionnement
on a rendu l'escaladent accessible à
tous donc maintenant on est on va
devenir un des leaders français donc on
en est on en est très fier on est
rentrer sur les géo aussi en 2020 à
tokyo on a on a deux athlètes de la team
verticale art qui qui va y participer
donc on en est très fier oui parce que
ça c'est aussi l'autre l'autre versant
l'autre pendant où vous avez aussi des
athlètes professionnels que ont
sponsorisé comment ça fonctionne c'est
exactement on laisse consolidant des
êtres dans leur projet professionnel et
leur projet de vie tout simplement
donc pour nous c'est une super image de
marque et ses big nous permet de
véhiculer à l'international nous valeurs
et les arcs les athlètes qui vont
participer pour les pour les prochains
jeux sont des athlètes toute la france
de saint quentin en yvelines
non pour nous c'est sean mc caul pour
l'instant ce qui qui a été sélectionné
qui va représenter sous la couleur du
haut de son maillot d'origine donc
canadien on à fanny gibert qui peut
encore contre 100 tickets on met
beaucoup d'espoir sur elle donc si tout
se passe bien il région de tokyo 2020 et
puis en huile 24 à paris sur la suite du
développement vous l'avais dit il ya
plusieurs salles qui sont prévus encore
surtout le développement économique que
vous avez aussi réaliser des appels de
fonds des levées de fonds de l'avs et
des nouveaux partenaires aussi
exactement on a fait il ya huit mois de
ça une levée de fonds avec notre
partenaire m capitale donc ça s'est très
bien passé on a pu en a deux en avance
sur notre développement donc on en est
tout à fait on en est très fier donc
pour fêter tout ça notamment il ya cette
compétition que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le hardeur boulder stronger
exalte deuxième deuxième volet alors ça
consiste en quoi vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est une compétition pour tous
les âges
tout à fait le matin d'aller en a les
enfants donc ils ont une vingtaine de
bloc à réaliser voilà sur un format très
libre de de deux heures et l'après midi
on a on va recevoir plutôt 200
compétiteurs avec 50 bloc pour les
départager plus des finales à 19h30 et
19h30 on aura le haut du panier de la
région et de la france
et puis après c'est festif il explorait
derrière d'animation qui est prévu
toujours toujours l'objectif de tout ça
c'est une fois de plus aussi de
récompenser fédérer vos adhérents ne
vient pas juste dans cette salle pour
pour s'amuser en solitaire et puis
repartir non c'est avant tout un lieu de
vie donc ce soir là permettent de
fédérer de communiquer entre eux entre
entre nous tous de faire un bel
événement tout simplement
ce sera donc le 1er février sa à la
verticale art sur saint quentin en
yvelines
un dernier mot ensuite s'il ya des
stages qui sont prévues en février pour
les plus jeunes tout à fait des stages
pour les plus jeunes qui seront encadrés
par hot par nos professeurs et vous
pouvez vous y inscrire bien évidemment
et encore des places il ya encore
quelques places est limité
merci en tout cas comme coquelin d'être
passé sur ce plateau nous parlait cette
opération et puis du développement de
vertical art cette success story comme
on en parlait il ya quelques instants
merci à vous merci comme chaque mercredi
nous passons maintenant à notre rubrique
dans les salles vos réaction aux
derniers films à l'affiché réactions
recueillies par aurélie rose
[Musique]
je m'appelle ciment du quart et les
privations série de la vérité repousser
les limites du savoir
voilà la mission des scientifiques était
rien j'étais terry et ses deux
aventuriers qui partent à la recherche
de yéti pour pouvoir montrer au monde
entier qu'ils existent réellement
et puis je vous raconte pas la fin ce
serait dommage leur commande pour un
public familial c'est très bien fait
peut-être que pour connaître quelqu'un
il faut d'abord les mets
avec ce désir sa mélancolie
j'avoue que je suis encore ému pourquoi
parce que j'avais lu le livre en fête
donc je trouve que ça reprend tout à
fait les sentiments de la petite famille
en fête tout au long d'une vie
l'histoire d'une fratrie
je trouvais ça très émouvant c'est
devait employer un mot pour mot
caractérise et qui choisirez quoi une
famille a peur congolaise que quoi voilà
donc le père qui est mort mais qui
revient en bois tout le temps d'un film
qui est très sympathique très beaux
paysages bon esprit et bien divertissant
[Musique]
cinéma a toujours avec une séance mardi
soir hier soir à jouy en josas de je ne
rêve que de vous c'est un film qui
retrace à l'extraordinaire histoire
d'amour entre léo et jeanne blum durant
la guerre le héros notamment du front
populaire en 1936 et son épouse ont
résidé dans cette commune cette dernière
a d'ailleurs créé une école et préparant
aux métiers paramédicaux le sujet de
mathilde et demi les ovations se sont
donné rendez vous mardi 28 janvier pour
rencontrer les acteurs du film
je ne rêve que de vous qui retrace
l'histoire d'amour de léon blum et jane
russell bac la projection du film était
suivie d'un débat avec l'équipe du film
léon blum est une grande figure de jouy
en josas
et j'aime bien l'histoire ma mère elle
m'a dit qu'il y aura elsa zylberstein et
d'autres personnes de cinéma du coup bah
ça m'intéresse pour le débat à la fin
emmi elsa zylberstein dans le rôle de
jeanne bloom est venu introduire le film
dans sa ville natale
ça fait genre en 25 ans
je suis pas rentré dans cette salle des
fêtes donc ça a même eu énormément c'est
l'endroit où je faisais mes gars là
dedans quand j'étais petit ça me fait
quelque chose de jouer une amoureuse
comme ça une famille répressive vivante
vibrante c'est toujours voilà c'est
toujours des rôles magique pour le
réalisateur du film
tout a commencé dans la commune de jouy
en josas quand il a visité la maison de
jeanne et léon blum
j'ai visité la maison léon blum au
moment de son inauguration et j'avais et
j'avais déjà ce projet de film en tête
le film se termine
à la maison léon blum sauf que c'est un
décor de cinéma évidemment mais
voilà je suis très content très ému en
plus je trouve qu une atmosphère très
joyeuse dans la salle on aperçoit et
d'inviter un peu particulière qui est
venu voir le film pour la sixième fois
la petite fille de jane blum
je vais très très bien dans toutes lés
cette histoire donc évidemment je suis
et je suis très très ému de le revoir à
jouy en josas en plus où j'ai vécu 15
ans un film qui rend hommage à
l'histoire du couple blum mais aussi à
leur maison devenue musée dans la
commune de jouy en josas
je ne rêve que de vous sorti le 15
janvier 2020 est toujours projeté dans
les salles à manier les hameaux aux
trois listes sont déclarés à ce jour
celle du maire sortant bertrand au lion
celle en cours de constitution encore de
dominique gratin et puis celle de lionel
lindeman jeunes et de man bon soir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes tête de liste mme annie
citoyens c'est une liste de temps ce
centre droit et aussi des adhérents
république en marche
vous siégez en tant qu élue d'opposition
depuis 2014 dans cette commune de magny
les hameaux
vous étiez candidat avec aurore bergé
qui est aujourd'hui députée pour autant
il n'y a pas d'investiture officielle
sur votre liste je parlais des
différentes tendances mais la fusion
nous a proposé plusieurs plusieurs
investitures et on a refusé parce que
l'on considère que c'est un enjeu
totalement locale
les considérations nationales sont à
vrai dire tout à fait secondaire ce dont
il s'agit c'est ma n'y est pas et pas
d'autres d'autres considérations par
contre on cache pas qui on est donc
effectivement on a des membres du comité
local manière marche qui ont décidé
d'intégrer la liste qui ont décidé de
participer parce qu'ils ont des
compétences vraiment très intéressante
donc c'est vraiment des gens qui vont
pouvoir apporter à la commune de
nouvelles compétences que à mon sens
elle n'a pas pour l'instant
et sinon on a 80 % la liste en fait
c'est d'aider à politique en fait donc
il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir une
étiquette particulière après moi je ne
cache pas que je suis plutôt de centre
droit pour que les gens sachent à qui
ils ont affaire j'ai pas enfin rang en
7les venise de centre droit dont il ya
c'est quoi les envois de 2014 il ya
beaucoup d'évolution vous reprenez une
partie la totalité des noms présents la
dernière fois la totalité non parce que
certains ont quitté la commune
on a on a des personnes qui étaient
vraiment très très intéressante mais qui
ont déménagé sans rémy les chevreuse par
exemple donc évidemment on va pas les
reprendre parce qu'on considère que
quand quand on se présente à l'élection
municipale il faut vivre sur la commune
par contre mon ombre jeu
il ya une grosse partie effectivement de
renouvellement depuis
oui oui lui 2014 nécessairement en 2014
votre liste dans votre liste avait été
battu le maire sortant avait totalisé 58
26 % comment vous pensez pouvoir
inverser ce ce score ce résultat qu'est
ce qui a changé depuis le dernier
scrutin
justement il ya le fait qu' on est six
ans après et que le maire a maintenant
un bilan
quels sont vos reproches sur ce bilan
justement ce qui va nous amener par les
autres membres
il suffit de regarder les engagements
phares qui l'avait pris
je pense à deux engagements en
particulier qui pour moi sont ces
symboles et même symptomatique de de ce
qu'on peut lui reprocher même s'il ya
aussi eu des choses très positives dans
ce qui a été fait il s'était engagé à
mettre en place un marché à manier les
mots et ce marché c'est très important
parce qu on a une commune il ya trente
ans encore il y avait des débats sur
est-ce qu'on va couper la commune en
deux est-ce qu'on va la scinder donc
c'est une commune qui a absolument
besoin de centres et de créer des liens
et donc ce marché extrêmement important
parce que c'est il permettrait à tous
les manier quoi de se voir tous les
week-ends de ceux de se rencontrer et
ainsi de suite
il a été promis à 6 ans et puis on est
six ans plus tard il ya toujours pas de
marché et donc au delà des étiquettes
des ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir
c'est est ce que un maire quand il se
continue quand il se présente à une
élection quand il propose un projet s
qui tient ses engagements ou pas est
donc là dessus c'est pas le cas outre
autre domaine où il s'était engagé à de
la modération fiscale s'était décrit de
façon très claire dans son dans son
projet et puis alors après les impôts à
manille augmentait de le loto des impôts
communaux a augmenté de 10%
donc moi pour moi ça c'est pas de la
modération fiscale et ça aussi c'est un
engagement qui n'a pas été tenue
ce à quoi le maire pour qui n'est pas là
et vous aurez l'occasion d'échanger
lorsqu'il y aura les débats qui seront
proposés sur notre antenne pourrait
aussi répondre qu'il ya un désengagement
de la part de l'état ceux-ci faire face
quand on est maire se bat c'est c'est un
discours qui tient qui tient
régulièrement
il se trouve que il ya beaucoup d'autres
mères qui n'ont pas fait ce choix là moi
je connais un certain nombre je suis
proche d'un maire qui lui a fait le
choix malgré le désengagement de l'état
de pas ne pas augmenter les impôts parce
qu'ils s'étaient engagés aux élections à
ne pas le faire elle n'a pas fait et en
réalité cinq ans après six ans après lui
il me parle plus du désengagement de
l'état et me dit il me parle de l'avenir
de sa commune est en réalité il a il a
fait face à ce désagrément des
engagements et sa commune est beaucoup
plus forte aujourd'hui ses finances sont
beaucoup plus fortes aujourd'hui parce
que il a fait face à cette difficulté
dans votre programme il ya donc cette
volonté de fédérer la commune autour
d'un marché notamment il ya aussi cette
idée de sortir du désenclavement c'est
un point qui revient régulièrement dans
les différentes campagnes sur magny les
hameaux de par sa construction sa
position géographique
quelles sont vos propositions justement
pour pouvoir sortir de cette commune un
peu de son éloignement du reste de 50
ans ni désenclaver un peu plus à
l'avenir allemand le le problème que
pose enfin nantes on faisait un moment
que c'est là c'est le domaine clé où il
faut agir parce que en fait tout le
reste devrait suivre
c'est à dire que si vous voulez des
entreprises s'installent à manille il
faut que
les salariés de ces entreprises puissent
venir à manier donc voilà si vous voulez
que les habitants trouvent des
opportunités à manier même il faut que
ces entreprises puissent puisse venir à
manille et ainsi de suite
donc nous ce qu'on propose pour sortir
de ce de ce désenclavement c'est
notamment des alternatives à la voiture
individuelle
il ya eu des pistes cyclables qui ont
été mises en place aux des bandes
cyclables mais elles sont pas sécurisées
donc personne ne s'en sert donc il faut
revoir tout ça elles ne sont pas
directes
il ya aussi dans
[Musique]
de ce désenclavement de la commune oui
ça passe par quoi d'autre le
désenclavement et le désenclavement de
la commune bien ça passe en augmentant
les bus en travaillant avec nos
partenaires de la communauté
d'agglomération pour augmenter les bus
le soir et le week end
j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu des bus express
qui ont été mis en place
tout ça c'est très intéressant sauf que
quand il ya des bouchons ça sert à rien
d'avoir un bus express par le travail
avec l'agglomération justement c'est
aussi l'un de vos points de programme
c'est mieux échanger avec
l'agglomération quelle que soit la
majorité a servi ce que vous disiez pas
d'étiquette par exemple mais c'est
quelque chose qui me frappe
quand je parle à l'extérieur de la
commune avec avec nos partenaires pour
préparer les élections
je constate que assez souvent ce que me
disent les
les partenaires de la commune c'est
qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à travailler
avec la commune de magny et donc moi je
considère qu'un maire aujourd'hui jeu
justement doit travailler avec tous les
partenaires extérieurs de la commune
qu'ils s'agissent de l'état qu'il
s'agisse du département qu'il s'agisse
de la région qu'il s'agisse de la
communauté d'agglomération qu'il
s'agisse des entreprises et ça c'est
vraiment un domaine où pour l'instant
les retours que nous avons sont négatifs
la campagne officielle va débuter lundi
3 février qu'on va se dérouler votre
campagne sur le terrain des réunions
sont déjà prévus en fait nous on
privilégie le
le porte à porte parce qu'on considère
qu'il faut aller voir les habitants
cecily à notre commune de faire une
réunion dans un coin de la commune alors
pendant une commune qui s'étend sur 7 km
c'est toujours réducteur donc vous
préfère pour l'instant aller voir les
habitants donc on discute dans tous les
quartiers en fait on a des binômes par
quartier qui ont vocation ensuite à
devenir maire adjoint au maire de
quartier c'est sa lite et du coup les
habitants les identifie c'est leur mère
de cartier ou de l'amour donc on va
continuer on a on a démarré on fait ça
depuis depuis décembre et puis à la fin
février effectivement moi un grand
meeting pour réunir tout le monde mais
on va surtout faire une campagne de
terrain on va aller voir les gens on va
discuter avec eux des réunions
d'appartement il ya ainsi de suite et
puis tout au long du mois on va décliner
nos propositions par thématique
merci beaucoup lionel lindeboom d'être
passé sur se classe au candidat donc sur
magny-les-hameaux à tête de liste et je
rappelle que trois listes sont déclarés
pour le moment nous quittons magny les
hameaux pour montigny le bretonneux
trois listes sont aussi déclarés mais
quels sont les enjeux du scrutin
premiers éléments de réponse avec ce
sujet de michael et demi d'euros la
concertation a débuté cet été pour la
réhabilitation de l'hyper centre de
saint quentin en yvelines
si le projet est piloté par la
communauté d'agglomération le territoire
concerne bien montigny le bretonneux
l'objectif étant de moderniser ce
quartier bâti dans les années 1980
qu'ils répondent aux problématiques
d'usagers de transports et de nature en
ville d'aujourd'hui la nature et
l'environnement c'est justement l'un des
enjeux de ces élections municipales
montigny le bretonneux aspire à réaliser
cette transition écologique la commune
n'échappe pas au contexte démographique
général et doit faire face à une
population vieillissante
un phénomène accentué par un coût du
logement élevé les jeunes familles et
nîmes antenne peinent à accéder à la
propriété et quittent la ville un enjeu
d'autant plus fort que montigny le
bretonneux accueille de nombreux sièges
d'entreprises comme récemment bmw dans
le quartier du pas du lac et dont les
salariés sont en pleine installation
dans ses nouveaux locaux des
constructions de logements dont des
logements sociaux font justement partie
de plusieurs chantiers communaux en
cours celui du forum des arts charles
aznavour à la place de l'ancien collège
bergson livraison prévue en avril 2021
mais également la réfection du club le
village fermé en décembre dernier pour
douze mois de travaux
55 à 60 logements font partie du projet
mais l'événement dont la nouvelle
municipalité aura à s'emparer ce sont
bien sûr les jeux olympiques de 2024
le vélodrome nationale accueillera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et l'île
de loisirs sell de bmx et et les
soixante dix huit vous proposera dans
les prochains jours d'un débat sur les
principales communes des yvelines pour
montigny le bretonneux ce sera le
dimanche 9 février à 11h en direct
première rediffusion le mardi 18 février
20h merci d'avoir suivi ce journal en
des vous demain pour un nouveau point
sur l'actualité locale
[Musique]